some of the things on today is true news
on top headlines celebrity males
inappropriately touching women make up
being stolen from popular youtubers
royalty coming out against computer
games what is the price sex songs so sex
just a head pop these sext all that and
more right in today's true news
subscribe
[Music]
hey Lawrence search or Mari Hardwick
for those who don't know this guy is the
lead meal in the hit show on Netflix
powerheads written by 57 it's not Game
of Thrones
do you know me but it's it's good surely
and he happened to bump into jay-z and
Beyonce are the chances people were not
happy with how he greeted her there you
go he's getting this photograph of Gaea
and then another kiss Oh double kiss two
kisses it was a nice day the first kiss
is enough how close as you get who were
mouths you just mean he kisses him out
so there's the first kiss one perfectly
fine I'd say that's that should be that
although she just doesn't seem
comfortable with that that's a fake a
smile you've ever seen but it's Beyonce
but then how close are we here oh that
she's definitely not anticipating
another kiss then jay-z's none the wiser
look at him [__] oh he chose a shock
right though it's like the ghost just
kissed my girlfriend kisses you she goes
he's walking he's walking [__] because
of that and then also he looks down each
[__] in his pants
maybe he's come back for another photo
jerseys like did we do this I can't
oh my single ladies he just starts
singing can the blood of the crowd and
out of nowhere oh he's lost it
he's just gotten to Beyonce more what's
up everybody welcome back to my channel
Marilyn Manson started his own YouTube
love it love it
Jeffrey stop who the last month of my
life has been an insane roller coaster
of emotions so many highs and so many
lows whenever anyone just starts talking
about their life like this as if it's
like so much better than everyone else's
we'd always Karen books my life for the
last month has been such a roller
coaster ride right now like I love I
have one hell of a life yeah honestly so
many cars so many girls it's almost so
good its energy draining yes Tufte to
keep going with it
sometimes I just want to lay in bed and
do nothing but then I realized just
life's just a ball and it's got as well
just gotta enjoy it I am in kind of a
state of shock right now
Oh literally when you're in an actual
state of shock don't know you never go I
mean I've had car accidents I've been in
hospital I genuinely had issues where I
thought I could [__] die yeah yeah
and at no point when I've been literally
in shock and like shaking are you going
well I'm in shock right now yeah
this is shock this must be what shock
feels like must be a brand new product
that I've been working on for over a
year has been leaked how many hours do
you think that that's been practiced in
the mirror that happy birthday mr.
president all that sort of volume it's
like we were saying a few months ago
there has to be an element of sociopath
in you to want to be on YouTube it's a
bit like making a coffee in it is that
some of us have just got a few more
teaspoons full of sociopath
yeah and we're looking at too much did I
put four teaspoons was I not spot you at
one one isn't yeah one is enough
unfortunately for us yeah it's the ones
with a lot who usually end up at the top
because they're the ruthless ones we're
too nice I'll stab you in the back yeah
you and I too loyal to each other yeah
all the time
we should have faked the fallout doing a
podcast afterwards absolutely drummed it
all up yeah one of us really camp one of
us really masculine that's that's what
works yes we didn't think ahead we've
been beaten to the punch on that one oh
yeah a boxer I am shaking and that is
the magic star concealer I'd love to be
in the minds of the people who went to
steal because to me if I became a robber
I'll be like all right we need to hit
the big stores that are holding all of
the TVs we need maybe maybe Robert
Porsche Ferrari garage we need to get
away with stuff that's got real money in
it but not it I don't have to carry a
lot what I don't want is to be carrying
bags of me they're also branded jeffree
star it's a I wonder who this belonged
to yeah I wonder who this belong to so
during this blue blood lodge which was
the biggest success of my career the
biggest launch and I just say if that
was your launch and that was your
biggest launch so far Illume still
guys you'll never guess lads lads and
everybody quick we're gonna need you to
come in and see this new makeup line is
not just some balloons in a normal
makeup show this is a great unite choc
buddy no I haven't hurt one as I've been
dealing with my birth mom being very
sick very sick now
no no funny I'm not nothing of that is
my birth mom who I came out of everyday
lost some people who they're a bit
boring in high school so they try and
dress up like goth to make them sound
more interesting and everything they do
is just a little bit like if you've been
to Tenerife they've been to 11 or
reflect everything has to be dressed up
just a little bit yeah because they are
interesting
you want to look boring but two weeks
ago the morning of March 15 I uploaded
the reveal video for the blue blood
collection that night at around 1 a.m.
one of my stock and shipping facility
warehouses was broken into and over 2.5
million dollars of product was stolen
from me that was about five puffers then
that's also about five minutes after the
insurance was confirmed on those said
products so so funny all things yeah
what are you accusing this place no no
no it's just good timing I'm glad it was
all insured it's been about two weeks
now since the burglary right and I've
been sitting here like when is it gonna
pop up online are they gonna try to sell
it wow you've really explored every
avenue of what my heart I like he's
really getting into the mind of the
great heist what are they gonna do it to
not keep it going let's lay gloves or
setting trends yeah it's all the rage
right yeah they're not they're no longer
stealing objects they're stealing trends
of course blue blood was announced right
that name or break-in these people were
professional I fully believe it was an
inside job so now to add to the list of
911 yeah and Geoffrey stars maker Blaine
we've got two confirmed inside job I
think George Bush was behind both for
these yes both of them he's moving on up
that wasn't enough from 9/11 wasn't
enough he's thinking how can i tottaly
getting deliveries at new facilities and
things have been spread around with
blueblood I wanted to make sure it was a
fortress um God's armed gods for the
make of the thing is though if you'd
been burgled for a lot of makeup that
was expensive you'd add an extra 500
grand on to the value you wouldn't do
that the insurance guys come around so
how much how much was all this makeup
worth and we're not really at this whole
YouTube thing yeah we're gonna do I
believe thousand again yeah more what
million probably more probably more but
you should know you're the business on
the chariot have you got the all the
stuff that was stolen as well so how
much was in two and a half million Oh
all right good enough for me well we'll
get our paid out yeah no party no
problem thank you I am in shock can I
get any more for that yeah probably
another half a million for that an
effect yeah thanks Geoffrey star to be
fair right I know this guy is a little
bit removed from reality because he's
obviously making so much money selling
makeup I do feel sorry for anyone who
has this [__] stolen it's just the way
he talks is a little bit sort of
self-important we can't not take the
piss out of that but I do feel sorry
from me sighs [__] he's literally just
trying to give his funds you know that
in the merch and that and I think you've
been very lucky you've never had any of
your makeup stone I've never had any
much because I've never had the ability
to get people around me who were
organized to help me make it so I'm not
right here none of that worry to go for
me because I've got nothing to steal you
couldn't passive-aggressive he's lost
nothing because he had nothing to have
nothing you can't lose nothing there's a
lesson for you just might yeah get rid
of all these what you need to do was get
an agency round you haven't got a
[__] clue me that would sort you
right out I know a few good people
an old four of Conor McGregor Paulie
Malignaggi
recently had a standoff with his good
friend autumn Laubach he got outta hand
poorly slapped him there's rumors that
they're gonna have a little bit of a
boxing fight which would be pretty cool
soon now the last person who slapped
autumn LaBeouf was could be no magamaev
and that sort of started this whole
rivalry that they had caught out
responds to the poorly slap and releases
a lot of pictures of Conor beating him
in a sparring match or at least it
appeared that way through the pictures
and then he goes after khabib and he
picks the one thing
that will probably trigger any man his
wife so this is a picture he posted of
khabib on his wedding day with his wife
could be his wife in traditional Muslim
wedding dress would look like lace cloth
over her face and corner post you
married a towel me or something like
that it was tasteless it was it was out
of order because you're poking at his
wife but a lot of people chicken it the
other way and said you're being racist
you're having a goat what she's wearing
and she's a Muslim now I don't think
that is really correct because for a
start you know Islam isn't a race
I think Connor is within his rights to
poke fun at a style of clothing on
anyone it's because it's curbs wife that
it becomes out of order because you're
bringing his wife into this and you know
beavers a very traditional man in that
he likes to keep it in the cage I was
just in the periphery of the cage I'll
be honest kitty was a bit of a [__]
gangster do you really wanna go this
road with a Russian guy like this is
Donnie he post the picture of Connor and
the girl who he allegedly [__] at a
party or whatever and said you are a
rapist and God will judge you that sort
of stuff this isn't the girl who he's
reportedly sexually assaulted he could
be was connected that story with a
totally unrelated picture to try and
make kind of look bad I might be slammed
down this is the type of [__] that could
come back in five years to blow up in
second you could win the fight now but
later on these are the type of guys who
could get you in a different way look at
the end of the day there for all of us
step the line here so as a fight
organisation you just say [__] it I say
[__] it let them fight gaming news now
Prince Harry is going to kill fourtner
apparently skal for a ban on fortnight
saying the survival game created to a
dick yeah if you're going to speak out
and your voice hauled weight like your
royal family member
yeah maybe speak out about important
[__] like his mother did alcohol and
tobacco that you could be raising
questions of or should we really be
putting those addictive yeah I just
think it's quite interesting that after
Prince Harry has a problem with people
shooting things online artificially he
would be a buffalo killer more addictive
then alcohol and drugs more addictive
than heroin fortnight's I've played for
tonight I've never taken heroin
yeah but I'd have to guess heroin would
be more
because fortnight wasn't that good for
those who don't know Joe Biden is the
former vice president to Barack Obama
Obama and it's come out recently that
he's inappropriately being touching
women he's next to two men there there
he is happy as Larry touch all the
problem not touching any other areas for
rocking that bus when you're just
minding your own business like this
woman is a strange behavior hey Brian
let's do this so yeah I'm fine with that
because we've known each other a long
time what are you doing do you think
yourself you like that is inappropriate
I don't know who those women are I think
he were inappropriately close to her
face yeah this is what I was thinking as
well because if someone gets a selfie
with me I'm like well if I come near you
I don't want to touch you all right I'll
be near you photo but I don't want I
look how you're getting you're selling
your soul out now and kids don't want to
touch you all right can we just all say
if you meet Lawrence of Canara touch me
don't [__] touch it I love how the
beta husbands look at him going you
better get your [__] hands off my
woman balls I'm Joe Biden Hells Angels
I'm sure she knows more about them than
you do right now I wonder if that guy is
a bit of a [__] in his eye you better
suck his dick for a country he is a
touchy guy he's a very touchy
don't do it Joe oh don't do it Joe only
Audie goes to kiss her as well she
clearly does not want to be kissed that
girl looks very uncomfortable oh my God
he's touching her that is so bizarre
we're seeing a repeat offender here and
that's where I start worrying a bit what
in private if this is what he does in
public what is he like in private this
is what he's supposed to be behaving
himself so what the [__] is he like in
private this is making me really
apologize yes now women are cute coming
out and actually saying like he's
inappropriately touched me and many
women are coming out and here we go
again so I think Joe also comes from a
generation where they were not they were
never educated about this and I think
they were like no they were educated I
don't think this is a generational thing
I think he's just creep and I'm saying I
think there are a lot of creeps in that
generation I don't remember the Grund I
doing that I feel like and I know this
is where they're all [__] in that
place and Joe Biden should not become
president
parent he's on a run for 2020 he's on a
run for the morgue in my opinion too old
for the office to write Bernie Sanders
all the way good news for those who were
sad about the loss of Nipsey Hussle
wrapper well beloved within his
community and someone who by all
accounts was just a stand-up guy to be
around
made some inspirational music for some
people so he was shot outside of his
shop in earlier the good news is that
they have allegedly found the guy who
was suspected of shooting him and it
looks like justice will be served
I mean you can't bring him back but it's
still good that someone who did
something so terrible yeah what we
brought to justice it's just matter how
many rappers get murdered isn't it like
you know in all the other music genres
it's you're pretty safe but in rattling
xxx tent a CEO and he died last year and
he was in for him like just doesn't
matter they just get rid of you no
matter what there's no real thought
about like taking a life I think the
thing that upset everyone more about
this was he was one of the good guys
so he wasn't someone who spread hatred
us but it was saying anything bad he was
a very positive figure I feel very sorry
for his wife who's also lost someone so
and his and his daughter jay-z the story
in this has set up a trust fund for her
and it's got 15 million dollars in it
with every terrible things that happen
there are poachers yeah jay-z is doing
really lovely things in the community it
makes you think though if you've got
that kind of money just to Dornier the
people he's got the kind of money to put
a hit out on that guy who's kissed his
missus or he better watch out yeah and
that is in the next episode of power
PewDiePie came back again to see was
again I thought it was all over
now mr. beast did that thing didn't he
and then everyone went and re-subscribe
sore he released a song called
congratulations juror yes I like you
his voice is such a sarcastic tone
doesn't matter what he says it's oh yeah
congratulations I got something on my
face was actually the only person I
think that is on YouTube who's more
sarcastic than you yeah
PewDiePie congratulations there's so
many shots fired
how are you feeling Robin you're our
Indian Oh going yes you guys are now
number two you're not my guy I want to
set up an interview with you as the
owner of t-series si se t-series that's
you put in your place there's one engine
you'll never get just going it is so
cool what is in India it's not any new
near India
it's not eating in India it's near it go
where is Robin the camera good it is a
picture of the founder of t-series their
two series was founded before PewDiePie
was even born
Gulshan Kumar wait he died 1997 Sudeep I
went back in time and killed him to win
the war and then kissed him on the foot
well I think you might like or hate this
just talk to him fighting no it's not
tag team Brian I think actually starts
with something you're gonna really like
but I disagree with culturally no now
he's got your attention
really got your attention there look
he's glued to it glued we welcome you to
the first team fighting championship
event we are using standard MMA rules
taken
for the victory is last-man-standing
this is going to be mental I'm so hyped
for this already yeah I'm not cause of
the woman well I mean the helpful can I
think can I thank Marius who introduced
me to this and sent this he said Brian
will love this so normally it's
one-on-one this my friend is 5 on 5
we're just gonna run at each other and
go bang some of them team up on others
are you seeing how big that guy is door
with the little one are that a bad
mismatch that isn't it
so I think they've deliberately
mismatched some of these guys as well
but look at them they are absolutely
just going to town so that guy's out
first I think basically the referee is
dog [__] but it's fun justice some of
these guys are just holding the other
guy down while they just hammer his head
that the sad thing is for me oh my God
look at that last guy he's basically
he's giving us no what's interesting
about it though so even if you have one
weak link in your team then you're very
likely to lose because as soon as it's
two-on-one you're screwed
as soon as you get that number supremacy
you're out this is then 3v3
in a cage so or who's gotten [__] some
of these guys are gonna see who's
getting [__] up is to look at this
[__] he's just oh he's not in
[__] that's gross yeah it's a bit more
measured in this one it's a bit more
like real UFC look at that it's crazy
isn't it a ref reach fight Wow
you know else I know we've got o always
promoters now this is medieval fighting
I'll tell you now I won't they've got
wooden swords well wooden but
everything's also blunt so there is
blunted metal in this and there is a
blunted metal axe then but some point in
its like that on someone's helmet over
and over again just bang imagine that
hitting you [__] you up being a big guy
holding heavy [__] like swords and
shields you have a massive advantage
there the bigger you are the better it's
gonna be for you in life in this
scenario you can move this yeah quick as
much as you're quicker like then gets
even better because I've been down a
real sort of UFC fighting hole now this
is climbing and fighting this is the
ring this is basically you know like
when you're a kid and you climb around
the funhouse yeah one was watching this
son do that with another kid and thought
anyway for some money in this basically
they just eat the [__]
each other until one of the Russians
dies yeah I mean look a straight on the
star that could have brought your neck
that looks like legit this then took me
down a somewhat of a rabbit hole this is
an Italian sport which is fighting on
football at the same time these men are
playing football whilst being able to
fight this looks like in a prison
somewhere feels like a prison but it is
Italy basically these guys is kind of
rugby football has handball sort of
thing whilst you basically you can just
fight got to get the ball in a goal
either end
I love Russell beneath us to try and
coach the [__] to be fair rough mini
toes with them well drill come back yeah
they've got to be your fist has got to
be calm buck when it hits the face of
the compacted head now Brian you you the
other day were complaining to me about
shitty English TV shows oh yeah we got
offered a few guests to be on a podcast
and I just said new well a few years ago
remember the show changing rooms new
right well it was a show where two teams
will compete against each other they
would almost be friends right and they
would get to decorate the friends living
room oh yeah or bedroom or whatever I
think I remember right this man is
called handy Andy handy Andy used to
sort of work with the wood and help the
people to do the stuff right and the
other woman is the design now the
designers come up with an idea of
freestanding shelves in a living room a
lovely idea in theory they fill the
shelves with these woman's prized
possession in my sort right the added
weight of all those books proved too
much for the freestanding shelves Oh
Andy Andy was his idea
no that was actually the designers idea
but oh my god Andy Andy holy execution
that's the thing often often I think of
a good idea productions isn't the small
poorly done because it's nothing to do
with you at all you wanted a corner
cabinet I gave you a nice hanging handy
Andy he came in with a bit of a Joe
Biden moment there where he put the hand
on the shoulder a thought not the time
you want a corner cabinet yeah
that's not what they got no if they just
listen to them yeah everything stays in
your you're resting everything on wood
that is planted on the ground it's not
hanging
yeah and also grandma's trailer is sort
of sentimental in
replaceable ah yeah things we go what's
the value of this and they just go five
big or 2.5 million I know Brian you
often go on about people who expose
their kids to the public these two
parents took it a step further for April
Fool's they told their daughter that
they were gonna give their dog away is
the daughter aware of April Fool's no is
it an April Fool's if they're not old
enough to know April Fool's is yeah and
they go if your parents go April Fool's
and you go what the [__] is April Fool's
mum who's April and then it goes into
this [__] absolute [__] you're a dad
now you shouldn't look like you're in a
[__] boy band or honestly why is
everyone such [__] at one point you're
gonna miss the catch yeah and she's
gonna go faced plug it into the dirt how
can you do that yoke it like literally
play with your kids emotions to a point
of like really upsetting your daughter
just for a [__] video title she's not
gonna learn anything from this issue
it's not gonna be a formative experience
in a good way
one of the sad things about having a pet
when you're a kid is that one day they
die and you have to sort of accept what
death is and it it's sort of a nicer way
of dealing with death for the first time
without losing an immediate family
member but it still hurts and it's a
nicer approaching a subject this is just
putting your kids are paying for the
sake of views and here she is pain also
the last thing that we wanted to tell
you is that tomorrow is April Fool's
tomorrow's if do you remember when David
Brent convinced dawn that she was
getting a disciplinary for stealing pens
as a joke and then told afterwards that
it was like she's like [__] off [__] off
there David Brent in this yeah this is
David pregnant he was a parent I also
loved that initially her face didn't
change because the parent went
since you went I'm not wearing this
constant she has no idea what it was is
she's still upset she's crying worse now
that we're not actually getting rid of
my dog my parents are just so [__] up
that he would convince me that for a
[__] YouTube video
how about it will [__] parents is our
thing if [__] should be in this house
I think that's this 26th of a pep you
literally poured water on my shirt a few
seconds ago when they new pants me what
I love is the justification of breaking
your daughter's heart you through poured
more over me earlier on so no wonder I
told you that the dog you loved was
going to live somewhere else you can see
in their intro their actual YouTube
channel what a couple of deluded [__]
they are so when they do [__] like this
it's like it's just confirmation that
well I made the instant snap judgment
that you're a pair of ignorant [__] and
you've confirmed that in the video so
sadly
thanks for proving my judgement spot-on
now you remember may remember a little
while ago we covered this woman why are
we watching this again well I've seen
this oh my bad
let me just go to her latest innovative
upload on April 30 Oh exactly the same
title I miss you so much surprise for
you
it's exactly the same [__] upload I
did two months ago what surprise how old
is this stop Sommersby alders [__] to be
that big by the way yeah I mean this
love story ceiling of [__] and he was
not in a mood for me he's not in a mood
I'm not in the mood for this look he
went what we do into it you know you can
see the [__] pot I'm not in the mood
I'm not in the mood I'm sorry Joel is
not in the mood lover she cuz I'm going
to be boiled alive yeah I funnier thing
not in the mood for that watches all his
brothers and sisters we've done exactly
the same way he knows it doesn't look
like fun I love that idea that there's
three of them in there a vari goes to
John he goes
is he getting hotter in yes just me me
yeah it goes down come
we accomplished it no it's it's
definitely getting hotter have you ever
seen the film final destination berry
yeah what the lobster version yeah I
think we might be in it I think death is
stalking us I think we're being at MIT
yeah no it's getting seriously hot now
I'm the Swain Barry I'm Barry yeah yeah
I think I might die my organs are slowly
shutting down so I'm gonna go clean this
and I'll be right back all right you
guys what did you do run him under a
[__] tux so it's all cleaned out look
how big this lobster tail is imagine if
you were on a date with a woman and she
just went that's the biggest
[__] steak I've ever seen oh
I'm about to eat this you know that look
how about a slob if I'm paying 200 quid
for a dinner uh and that's the kind of
reaction I'm looking yeah you want them
to pick up everything off the plate and
go look I see this chip right I won't
have much particular yes it's the best
muscle I've ever heard yeah Brian you
see you see this mac and cheese it's
turning my hair brown but this is the
best place the best Macanese I've ever
had I got first-degree burns to show you
this food all right oh my god straighted
now you've gone you Trump her ass must
explode after this has happened there is
no other way around you know your arse
is like that night it must just be like
a point out in the like prolapse like
this [__] must just continuously just be
trained fished it out
I've got a small hose just sort of
attached to it she's literally just like
it's just garlic butter and fished with
exporting from her but the noise at the
start of the video is actually just her
shouting with her feet not even touching
the floor just Larry in Dumb and Dumber
part of the problem is Barry was sitting
in the freezer with his mate Kenny the
crab we are doing a five pound king crab
I was going to do the 10 pound crab but
oh oh god she didn't want to admit them
but she's got this problem to their
butthole
it must be she's like I just can't go
through [__] all of that out I can't
do that myself she's got other plans on
Sunday I want to go out do some things
she can't literally be within stone's
throw away of the [__] now Brian this
woman isn't the only repeat feeder we
are finally doing the 15 pound lobster
mukbang as you can tell by the title it
is so hot today in California and I'm
going to show you how cool my shirt is
it says stay humble in case I'm start
getting ideas above your station you
think you saw now I've eaten the 15
pound lobster I'm bath and everyone else
stay humble see what my mom is up to
just put some shrimp in see that
actually looks pretty decent yeah I
would eat that trying to somewhere they
love eating big portions now their mom's
a good cook
okay I want to see what her lifestyle is
yeah what is her life what is she doing
it is 9:50 I'm 10 minutes away from
getting my vagina wax
welcome to oversharing nation what the
[__] is YouTube well you choose like a
video platform where people upload
videos of their personal everyday life
is clearly I mean very personal it's
good general I was very very nervous
leading up to this but I think I am
hella hella Geechee Brian say it with me
where hello hello Gucci yeah must be for
mechele's here she is coming with me
from shell patents which other hand pop
I love the fact that Michelle is dead
friends and she's hooked up in a
basement I just thought I'll be using
that buzz this is very woody imposes in
it oh she's definitely had too much [__]
put into one lips girls if you're
watching I don't think there's an s the
necessity for all these women have all
these [__] huge lips like if you
insist on doing this shot the soldier
just know when to stop because that's
too much money you look like you've had
an allergic reaction
she can barely shut her [__] mouth
singing that is just permanent they dyes
her it'll go down it won't move on man
had I think two thousand subs for me
when we first met him sort of speak
since we started promoting him he has
ended up on the trending page of YouTube
as the creator on the rise tell us we
don't have power you tell us we know
we're making stars yeah and to be fair
to blue van man he's probably one of the
people who he's not an accidental star
this man was destined for this not a few
our close friends who we've sort of
featured in the past before on certain
videos so I feel a bit like they haven't
had that show you're not blue van man
yeah if you are one of our flames
you're not blue van it's not our fault
you're not him yeah don't put that on us
that's on you
some people are just not born with it
maybe it's blue van man we're doing a
[__] look bunk and I have my man we
ordered burger for this Lawrence yeah we
pick our rings oh so guys this is a 15
pound coke throughout call it drinks
these little oak oh bloody I don't know
what they are to be fair they just tell
me what they look like to you are they
something that you can sneak into bloody
clubs and stuff Oh pubs and Glastonbury
I think the people of Glastonbury
arsenic and where were slimmer than that
or should we try and get some very sour
shots in yeah come on big boys shipment
big boys [__] come he doesn't approve on
mud for a minute
you love tipping your chips into
milkshakes oh wow
he doesn't dip the chip in a little bit
he drowns the chip it like literally are
we for or against that in the comments
beneath all that people have started
selling dips of milkshake so you'd have
to buy a full mix adjusted up your chips
in I'm not so sure about this dude all
good all tomato sauce for me yeah Tommy
Kane someone's broken into his hopes of
stealing honours make up the pork hits
the pork I love that he's having this
before dinner just setting himself up
for a nice meal some people maybe a beer
maybe you're winding him up or sour
cherries yeah you've been asking for
Anki Steve to do more reviews
somebody says getting to reviewed
alcoholic beverages on key Steve's blind
and if he gets drunk it's not a pretty
sight to blind people get sort of drunk
in a weird way I think the point is as
units you need to keep those sensors on
time yeah so you can get around the
house or around we might have him pissin
on the wall or something if you want oke
Steve to have a beer with me like Stone
Cold Steve Austin um give me a hell yeah
he might be in my top three favorite
youtubers this close when people see me
oh who do you watch on YouTube he's
probably one of the main guys I want to
this point yeah you know I love his he's
just said the phrase give me a hell yeah
I've got a Sarah I love it where to now
minutes in there was [__] review of a
soft no sign of a sock anyway well
mention you're a rock star you know what
he's so affirmative there are things
that times I wake up I think I quite
like you as an alarm I just want to wake
up to him going fair play to you you're
a rock star I want some sort of like
Dallas phrase from him yet we're just so
stood and assembled we should make a
soundboard for blue van man and then
call Maine lobster come to a prank call
yeah this video is live and man in the
future not a review but what I'm going
to do with loads of shoutouts what we'll
do first is I want to read all these
shout outs out because I'm getting so
many people coming up as sending me a
message saying they want to shout out
and a few people who are watching my
videos don't want to hear a shout out so
I can understand that people want a a
little bit of part of the blue van ride
and a lot of people don't eat a yummy
yank I'll just describe YouTube shoutout
sitting in the yang out on the public
pressure I feel like I'm watching a
parliamentary this is this guy and I
still don't what his name is but he is
under more pressure than John Terry felt
the whole time after the races fall out
coming to serve Lou fun man for Prime
Minister is he don't like me you don't
like me if you do like me brilliant
keep watching me keep following me it is
totally your choice I'm not one of those
who says like and subscribe
oh my god got one of them he's not one
of them I actually do think this guy is
throwing shade it with any being great
watching him again I mean he's got our
support been a good show me I have a
good life I always enjoy doing this fun
fun see you a lot as well for watching
appreciate it
we're not the type to us for you to like
and subscribe not one of those [__]
houses you know we hang isn't it a space
away yeah a lot the content but if you
should choose to LIKE and subscribe
thank you very much kamasutra thanks for
watching we'll see you there